- [Voiceover] In a city infested with
crime, disorder, and
chaos, there's one group
dedicated to upholding justice.
The Fair Use Friends!
A crime fighting team of
vaguely familiar superheroes.
There's Superbman!
- I'm from another planet!
But not Krypton!
- [Voiceover] Wunder Woman!
- Nein!
- [Voiceover] She's German.
Man-Spider!
An ordinary spider bitten
by a radioactive man.
- My human sense is tingling.
- [Voiceover] Aquamen!
And Batman!
Vampire Batman!
So look out evil-doers!
Because the Fair Use Friends
are ready for action!
The Fair Use Friends are facing
many copyright infringement lawsuits
and are technically not ready for action.
- I thought we had this taken care of!
- [Voiceover] To be continued!
We're going to see.